let's do let's do this guy
we're going to do it by slices which
we're more familiar with and in this
case it's easier
and then we'll do it by shells okay you
can do any volume either way
sometimes as you'll see one is better
than the other one which is more
superior
okay so let's quickly draw it right
let's draw this guy
square root of x right so you're getting
that half of that sideways parabola like
so
okay we're from naught to four
now we're going around the x-axis like
so
okay so first let's do it by slices
because we're more familiar with that
if we're doing it by slices which way do
the areas go do they go up and down or
do they go left and right
if i want slices out of this thing i
think you want to take a shape like this
don't you
you want to take an area like that right
once you take that area
and you rotate it uh-huh there's your
annular disc it just so happens that
your inside radius in this case
will be zero okay so let's actually fill
okay
so how am i going to do this line in
here okay
by slices the volume is equal to okay
now the limit will be this time it'll be
x approaching 0. see that it's getting
thin see how important the diagram is so
you get all these pieces right
delta x is approaching 0. what are my
values i'm going to go from
x equals 0 to 4 because they're the
boundaries i've had provided to me
then you've got okay here comes the area
daniela disc
right the volume i should say big radius
squared
little radius
what is this radius what's it equal to
in this case
it's equal to like it's a vertical
distance it's y right
ah but because of the axis that i
am going to be integrating across in a
second right i don't want this in terms
of y
i want it in terms of x right so instead
i should put in here
square root of x that's the y but it's
it's squared isn't it
it's big radius squared minus the little
radius squared which just happens to be
zero
and delta x there you go there's the
width of each one okay turn this guy
into an integral
there we go pi is out the front zero to
four
it's just that that's all okay let's
quickly do it
uh pi there what do we get
x gradle 2 from naught to 4
the naught's going to disappear that
looks like 16
on 2. so it's sounding like 8 pi cubic
units so far so good okay
now how do we do this by shells
okay draw yourself a new diagram it
doesn't have to be huge or beautiful but
you have to be able to read information
of it
okay the graph is going to be the same
and the boundary is going to be the same
four
still rotating around here okay but this
time
i'm not going to be choosing these kinds
of chunks
i'm going to choose a chunk like this
see i'm parallel to the axis of rotation
now
okay so when you rotate this around
that's what gives you this um or here's
an example
okay there you go so there's one of my
shells okay
so start off volume is equal to okay
we start by saying limit now the
width that i'm going to reduce and take
the limits to is a um it's a vertical
width right so that's why this is going
to be delta y and it's going to approach
zero
okay now because i'm talking in terms of
y's now
right i'm actually not interested in x
boundaries anymore i'm interested
in y boundaries okay so i'm thinking
this way can you see when i add up all
of these
right there's one there's the next one
and the next one and the next one and
all these they're all going to add up
okay
so what are my new boundaries they're
not not to four it'll be
from from naught here up to this is
going to be two
isn't it because the square root of four
okay so there you go that's fine
okay now i'm up to this stage
okay to pi
now what's the radius and what's the
height
be careful okay here's the radius here
okay radius there's there's the
cylindrical shell
now i'm doing everything in terms of y's
okay so how shall i express that
distance
it's just y isn't it that's all that
that distance there is y
okay so the radius r is y
when i want the height it's this guy
here that's that's the height of my
cylindrical shell now this is a bit
harder you have to be careful
okay hmm take some values
and be careful over here for instance if
i take that value up there
okay um what for this value right
what will the height of the cylindrical
shell be
and the answer is it'll be four
right that distance there is that okay
really be careful
see see this distance is for ah but this
lingua cylindrical shell
that i get from up there is actually
that guy
it's going to be the shell that i'm
after the height will be zero
okay so in fact the real height that i'm
after here
is not four four is what this distance
is all the way along
it's actually four minus
whatever x value you're having okay
um but i don't want x right i want this
in terms of y's that's what i'm going to
integrate with respect to in a second
right
so how do i write this in terms of y's
well yeah x is going to be y squared
isn't it
okay see that right so now i say that's
4 minus y squared ah
that's the height of my cylindrical
shell see how careful you have to be
4 minus y squared there you go radius
height i need one more piece to make a
volume
delta y delta one the thickness
the thickness of the shell okay great
let's turn it into an integral
what's going to come out the two pi will
come out the front
i'm going from naught to two what's this
going to become
four y minus y
cubed yeah
people are looking at me funny have i
have i done something wrong okay
that's right okay i think i'm okay with
respect to y
okay now i can integrate now i can
integrate 2 pi's still out the front
this will become
2 y squared this will become y to the 4
on 4
from not 2. okay
i'm gonna better crunch the numbers on
this one i'm going to get 2 times 2
squared
which is 8. here i'm going to get
16 sorry yeah 2 to the 4 is 16 on 4
which is 4. the zero one's just going
well i should put that in trimmer
there you go okay 2 pi times 4
is the same volume that we got before as
you'd expect
okay
so be careful um you
remember i said before you've got to
have the diagram right it's very very
important so you can get pieces like
this